[Music]
foreign
welcome back for a brand new episode of
the after show I'm your host for the day
Perry nemeroff and this time around
we're covering an especially big movie a
movie that we had to wait 13 years for
we are breaking down Avatar the way of
water we're digging into the visuals the
story and the franchise's potential
moving forward as well before we even
start our conversation though I need to
warn everyone that we are going to be
talking Avatar the way of water spoilers
in this video so if you haven't seen it
yet it's all good go out and see the
movie and then come back and check out
this conversation the warning is out
there it's official it's over and done
with your final spoiler warning happens
now if you want to live here
you have to ride
let's do it
and now that that's taken care of I get
to welcome a guest that I'm very excited
to introduce right now and I'm nervous
to introduce because I guarantee you he
will put me through at least one
existential crisis during this
conversation hello and welcome
I like am I a spoiler am I an avatar the
way it looks your last warning this man
will existentially crises you about the
way of water and I got some I'm ready
this is uh James Cameron gets me this is
gonna be fun I am I'm conditioned at
this point to expect that I have like
fortified my brain I'm ready it'll be
okay it's working for life let's get
into it by checking out what's doing on
the Tomato Meter right now looks like
Avatar the way of water is certified
fresh at 78 and the movie has a whopping
93 audience score which is something
else the critics consensus on this one
States narratively it might be fairly
standard stuff but visually speaking
Avatar the way of water is a stunningly
immersive experience so koi I've been
hearing the word Masterpiece thrown
around quite a bit with this movie and
personally I can be very sensitive about
using that word and do only use it for a
select few films out there but how do
you feel about applying that particular
word to way of water is that what you
give it so uh the word Masterpiece I
reserve for very few films uh but James
Cameron does have a few of them I
consider T2 a masterpiece I consider uh
Alien a master aliens apologies uh
Masterpiece but I I can't quite allow
that word to be something you use for
things that are as visually spectacular
with as Lena's story I think that the
storytelling in a movie is as important
as the visual But It's tricky because
there are movies that get away with
really really incredible dialogue that
can be shot poorly and I think this is
the first time I've ever seen the
equivalent of the inverse of an
incredible script shot poorly I've
gotten through movies that were shot
very very very badly or the sound was
bad but it was so rich that I was
invested this might be the first time
that something is almost a masterpiece
just from a visual standpoint like the
AV of it all is very interesting when
you go the other way this movie is very
lean on plot to me it's something I have
seen before but it's something I've
never seen before while being something
I've seen before yeah we'll get into
some of the the story points shortly but
so I can't call it a masterpiece
personally
I'm so torn on the matter because like I
already said I'm sensitive about using
the word I don't want to just throw it
out and kind of reduce the meaning of it
when I apply it to a film but
I've never seen anything like Avatar the
way of water visually and as someone who
was kind of lukewarm on the first Avatar
movie like I was wowed by a lot of the
uh the features that everybody else out
there was pretty impressed by back in
the day I wasn't someone who went back
to the theater to see it over and over
I couldn't get over how Florida I was by
what this movie looked like and what
they were able to accomplish visually
again I'm not getting into my thoughts
on the story just yet but
when you think about what it feels like
to be basically transported to the Moon
of Pandora and truly feel as though
you're being fully enveloped by this
fictional existence and have it work as
well as it does
man kind of want to use kind of want to
use the Masterpiece word I've only like
that word I I feel like has to be
something that sticks with me in
multiple ways I don't feel like there
was anything narratively that like a
metaphor or a life Revelation or a
character that's gonna stick with me and
I do feel like there are dozens of
visuals that will and that's why I bring
up the dialogue based films that don't
have strong visuals because often there
are times that like a single line of
dialogue can strike me and it'll stick
with me in quotes like resonate and I
don't have the visual in my head I just
feel that emotion this is the inverse
where I don't feel like there'll be ever
a moment of like impact that is is
resonating here it's going to be
resonating here so I don't know if that
is fair to not describe it as a
masterpiece because this is a one-of-one
experience the first time I've gone wow
I've never experienced something so
visually so ocularly that didn't hit my
heart in quite the same way and that's
not to say this is a bad film that's not
to say this is a good film this is a
great film but is it a masterpiece a
masterpiece implies to me a 10 out of 10
a 5 out of five a hundred percent or
something in the top 90 percentile and
and to me I can't allow
um something that didn't make me uh uh
look at life differently a masterpiece I
I it needs to move and maybe that's too
high but it needs to make my life
different to be a masterpiece I feel
like there's no better place to go at
this point than to dig deep into the
visuals that we do see here just like
this revolutionary technology here that
I still can't quite wrap my brain around
so again it took us 13 years to get to
an avatar sequel that is a whole lot of
time to take to make the next film in a
franchise like this so
koi did do you think that that time paid
off do you see 13 years worth of
advancements in avatar The Way of water
ultimately I do ultimately and it's
really interesting that you know the
first film changed special effects uh in
a way that only James Cameron came he
said he was going to change everything
he changed everything so 13 years later
how do you
see something for the first time again
you can never have a first impression
twice so it's really hard to have a
sequel that's so visual based That's So
based in wow and yet he did I I
definitely was wowed again I definitely
got that oh my God I'm on Pandora again
I definitely got the they can do this
again but to a different scale because I
think what he did was he
was revolutionary in Avatar and he was
evolutionary in the way of water but in
the way that he would evolved his own
technology was almost more impressive
the moments that you felt the
interactivity between someone that was
actually there like spider and someone
that wasn't real because they were a
giant blue Navi was seamless and I do
find in the first film just because of
where it was 13 years ago there are
moments I was very aware of the actors
versus the navi there are maybe seven
minutes out of this three hour run time
that I was aware that I wasn't watching
something that was real I I was so
immersed throughout that I fully felt
like I was watching something that did
exist and that's a one-on-one experience
like there there is no special effects
movie to date short of way of water that
is this evolutionary to the entire genre
of Blockbuster I've seen a bunch of
um live action animation hybrid movies
where you know I I enjoy them and I
think they work well enough I don't
think I've ever seen in a movie quite
like this that makes me completely
forget that performance capture to CG
character like that that character is
not a real living breathing human being
that at least in my mind while I'm
watching the way of water like exists on
a far away Moon the navi feels so
incredibly real and again I think that
the navi work really well in the 2009
film this was a different kind of like
believability tactile Reach Out And
Touch it they're a living breathing
being that actually exists there and one
of the most impressive things to me is
is kind of what you were just talking
about a little
the idea that you could have a navi
character next to a human being and not
for a second does your mind ever think
that's that's not real that's movie
that's that's the thing is I I love
talking about movie Magic movie Magic is
a special thing this movie is so magical
it made me forget that it was movie
Magic happening specifics now koi do you
have any particular wow worthy moments
in avatar The Way of water as far as the
visuals go that you think are really
gonna stick with you you know there's a
bunch that jump out that I think a lot
of people have talked about but I want
to talk about one that I don't I don't
know gets enough credit
um when you go underwater and you
experience that first like plunge and
everyone in the reviews has talked about
like once we were underwater I was so
enthralled with this new world for me it
was the second after that when they're
actually exploring the village uh what I
loved was the intricacy of the actual
physical world they built above the
water I was so impressed with the
tribe's Village feeling
um useful like everything felt like I
could see how everything operated like
sometimes they show a fictional world uh
wakanda forever didn't feel like it
lived in like to me when they went
underwater I was like that's dark and
like it just didn't feel like the people
like the the telecons felt like vibrant
and alive and bright and like they'd be
proud of of you know art and things in
their culture and they had the Sun but
everything else was dark and kind of
like yeah we're underwater and I get
realism versus artistic interpretation
but what I loved was they were able to
make it realistic with artistic
interpretation by putting it just above
the water and things felt like this
blend of wicker and Island and things
felt like they were of an island you
could visit but you actually can't and
things felt practical that but alien it
felt like the uh tangible version of the
navi themselves and none of it was real
so I was so impressed at the fact that I
was like I could go there and hang out
for a night in these awesome Cabanas I
think it's kind of similar I think I was
most wowed by things that were happening
like in the in between in terms of on
land versus something connected to water
like in particular every single time a
navi character was like getting rained
on or maybe emerging from the water it
felt or like even just stepping in the
shore as the water goes up on the sand
like all of that felt so real and and
use this word again tactile like I could
feel the water drizzling off of their
faces and also just like the level of uh
the level of detail and just the way the
water glistens off of them is so
incredibly realistic that it blew my
mind but my real answer to this
particular question that I posed to you
was totally watching a dude's arm get
sliced off and like fly into the ocean
it's like scary answer possible this is
so hard moment I saw it coming like I
was what because it like that that takes
a while to play out to fruition and I'm
like no way no he did it he did he cut
that guy's arm off also I think the most
emotionally resonant movie uh moment of
the movie to me the moment that
resonated the most was
um The Wailing being so horrific in that
those whales aren't of our world and
they're only Loosely tied to our world
in that they look like whales like we
don't I don't have a lot I like whales
they're great I don't have a lot of
connection to the whales I'm not gonna
lie like I I know how bad wailing is I
can't watch those videos I don't watch
those videos I don't need that in my
head so maybe that's why this was so
jarring is is it was forced upon me and
I had to acknowledge how awful people
can be and again that's the that is the
story elements I connected to are he is
telling a story about us through these
creatures he is telling a story about
our planet through Pandora and I did
connect to the whale in a way I wouldn't
have expected this this preacher was
able to make me feel for it in a few
lines of dialogue with a few incredible
eye shots and this connectivity where we
never heard its voice but my problem was
it kind of undermined a lot of the first
movie for me in that there's so much in
the first movie about connecting and
bonding and finding your way in nature
and these Navi just show up in this
water Planet they're like what up we got
telekinesis I can talk to whales like I
didn't buy the pop-up yellow Papyrus
font where he's suddenly like hello I
can speak to you like I didn't feel that
at all so the fact that I was able to
visually connect to the whale dying and
feeling for it so badly when I was like
bruh why is this whale telekinetic it
was a very weird dichotomy it took time
for them to understand each other it was
seven minutes they were like what up bro
I believe the processing processing what
up bro we'll get into it with story
because lox Journey was hands down my
favorite part of this movie but before
before we touched story beats right now
one more visual question for you what do
you see in Avatar the way of water that
you think will actually like actively
get to see change the way that movies
are made in the near future I think it's
the new bar
um and that's that's so broad but I I
don't think we accept uh and obviously
budget's gonna change this movie is you
know cartoonishly expensive for now but
like everything gets cheaper as it's
developed like you know like it's like
the Olympics once someone breaks that
record it's like everybody's breaking
the record like once you see that it can
be done it's been done and thus it's
possible so I think that now we know
what's possible we've we've changed the
standard of realism I think we're going
to see different textures uh I think the
big thing that isn't talked about in
this world uh enough is that the
background mid-ground and foreground all
felt just as real uh a lot of times when
you look at special effects movies
they're like we really focused on the
navi but the planet was a mess or the
middle between like the established
World they played in and the characters
there's that weird like well I know
they're gonna pick that up it's got a
black line around it like a 70s animated
film like there's a lot lot of times
tells this movie didn't have tells so I
think the biggest Evolution that we're
going to look at is this is the
beginning of seamlessness there is any
seamlessness now that is going to change
Cinema I wonder if this particular piece
of technology actually played a part in
what you were just describing but I had
asked the producer John Landau about you
know what new thing did you guys come up
with for the way of water that you're
most looking forward to seeing other
films out there put to use not just your
future Avatar movies and he brought up
the idea of using simulcam and explains
how on the initial film they did have
that technology and that technology is
basically so a director can like compose
a frame while being able to see their CG
character even if the CG character isn't
in reality in front of their eyes on set
the thing was back then that CG
character was only visible in front of
everything
there and the example he used was a
character for example couldn't like walk
behind a desk and you'd be able to
visualize that in what you were looking
at but now they have that technology
whereas CG character can walk behind
something and that just feels to me like
it gives a director so much more range
when it comes to what you were just
describing being able to compose the
layers of a shot and not necessarily
what is front and center in a frame also
think about our gray matter right like
we've gotten more accepting of this
reality think about like any director
working right now has seen more CGI in
the last 10 years than they saw in the
rest of their lifetime anyone anyone
that watches movies is aware of the
z-axis in a different way every great
director is aware of the z-axis and a
depth of field sense but now we're
filming in a different era look at the
volume look at what we're able to do in
real time so not only do you have
simulcam which is incredible I didn't
know they could have layers in real time
but when you're like I did a similarly I
did a presentation for Sony where they
talked about their
um they're basically having real-time
backgrounds that the director can be
directing simultaneously with their
actors that are moving in real time so
you don't have that silly car thing
anymore like it's it's a real-time
multiple directing but that's directing
two things simultaneously this what
you're describing is directing an
infinite number of things simultaneously
and thinking just in the the mindset
it's like I always talk about the
internet we we are having to learn in
real time how to process a certain
volume of data at all times our next
Generation people that are are 15 now
can understand a rapid amount of data in
a different way than we have because
that information capacity isn't new to
them that's not something they had to
develop directors that are coming up now
are going to see Avatar and go like well
that's what movies can be and they're
gonna know how to look at a shot because
of this technology and frame it a
different way like James Cameron is
birthing an entire new generation of
filmmakers and that's what makes this
unique this allows for this is this is
an X exponential increase in technology
it's not linear it's exponential it's
staggering without a doubt I feel like
it's probably also necessary to point
out that he did have an extreme amount
of money and it's an extreme amount of
time that maybe wouldn't be afforded to
all filmmakers out I think student
filmmakers don't have cyborgs I'm just
glad that ultimately it does feel to me
like he used all of those resources and
that time to improve the visuals to such
an extent and really have the
possibility of changing the game for
filmmaking going forward koi the time
has come
let's get into some story details here
a criticism of the first film was
obviously that it had an unoriginal and
weak story did you feel that way and if
so is this movie something that improves
on that or is it kind of the same thing
all over again it's really interesting
because the first film to me and I know
this is trike but some things are cliche
for a reason I I definitely felt the
dances with Dances with Wolves meets
FernGully thing so and I and I get that
that's that's contrived because that is
like the story beats are very similar in
so many ways but what's interesting to
me about the second one is it didn't
feel like one or two movies it felt like
a genre of movies this to me felt like a
sequel so like I didn't feel like I was
going through like color by numbers but
I did feel like I was walking a familiar
path so like I definitely knew what I
was getting for I definitely knew how I
thought the third act would go and it
did and I definitely felt like I
expected certain this is spoilers so
this is your real last warning I
definitely when they introduced more
than two children's like one of them's
gonna die like I definitely was aware of
death from the opening as soon as I
thought that I was shocked I was shocked
that they went as far to kill one of the
Sully children oh as soon as they
introduced so many of them and I
couldn't keep track of them I was like
one's dead and then as soon as I got
used to which like so then the story
moments played through very
traditionally right like the one that's
more traditionally
um successful versus the underdog the
Underdog's gonna make it the
traditionally successful One's Gonna Die
probably the older child so the middle
child has to become the older child it's
a walkabout it's a furthering of manhood
especially a male child taking over the
dominant male especially an underdog
male child than having to identify with
the adult male child while he dies in
becoming the Father Figure to the
younger it's all very like I've seen
that I think I think ultimately loock is
on his own path and that's part of the
point but before I get specifically to
that more more broadly I can very much
recognize the flaws in the original film
but I do have to say that in revisiting
it now because isn't a very different
movie consumer back in 2009 compared to
who I have become today I did appreciate
the pairing of of what felt like a more
traditional classic story paired with
this just like incredible reveal of what
Pandora is and how this Avatar
technology worked there's there's
something about that type of
Storytelling paired with those ideas
that I think does work fairly well
together but I'll I'll agree with you in
terms of the evolution of the story and
this feeling like like a sequel and
while I was able to identify some more
traditional character arcs where maybe
not in terms of the death but other
things I could kind of predict where
they were going a little bit I do think
that between the performances and the
time and really like the three hours
that they take to sit with these
characters and flesh them out and
understand the family Dynamic I think a
lot of it worked well enough
some character arcs are strong than
others though I agree with you and
that's what's interesting is is I can't
put my finger on my disconnect like I
don't need things to always break the
mold every time there's a story I don't
need like I like traditional stories I
enjoy the Marvel movies not not a lot of
them are doing something that's gonna be
revolutionary storytelling wise they do
have evolutionary elements but like I
know how they're going to go generally
and that doesn't bother me what's
interesting to me is I definitely felt
like I was uh about 20 minutes ahead at
all times and my brain was wandering as
opposed to living in it I kept going
like oh I bet this is going to happen to
Jake and then it did and so I was like
cool and it just it didn't like it
didn't hit because I was going like hey
that thing I was right it's a thing that
like again it's hard to put into words
but even though I could feel where
things are going I I didn't have that
and I think I think that speaks to the
visuals again and just how immersive
every single frame is there's always so
much to look at and I could always feel
the complexity of the internal struggle
of the key character that a particular
moment was focusing on and I'll walk
into the Loach storyline with that point
that was above and beyond to me the most
powerful character transformation in the
entire film he he went basically from
from stubborn Outcast who was in a more
childish sense marching to the beat of
his own drum in in defiance of his
parents and what they wanted to
understanding that that Outcast quality
isn't something to be shunned or or have
to shed in order to appease his parents
but but celebrated and accepted and
embraced in order to make things better
for the navi and his particular Clan and
his family going forward I thought that
his stuff was so incredibly beautiful
and I think that goes back to the big
brother and just like the idea of him
being able to look up to and respect him
but ultimately not feel the pressure to
conform to the example that he said and
like what a brilliant message to send to
like I was about to say to send to kids
like forget kids every living breathing
human being on this planet that tries to
live up to certain standards that they
think are musts and then they ignore the
special qualities that make them unique
to begin with so that particular story
arc was my absolute favorite across the
board I agree lowak was uh the Highlight
as far as characterization and I
honestly like again with the with the
expectation of the brother dying in
order for him to have his story it felt
like more a piece of his story that his
brother died and I think that bothered
me a little bit because like oh of
course he can't become his own man until
his brother dies there he goes and I was
kind of just waiting for that the whole
movie so he could become his own man and
then I was like oh and then he's got to
make sure he parents his father that way
completes the journey and then when that
happened I was like now the next movie
I'm very excited to find out what's
original with him but the transformation
starts before the brother passes oh yeah
yeah but it wasn't complete like it had
that was the bow right like so I kept
waiting for I I kept I kept wanting that
transformation to happen knowing it was
the cost was the brother like he was the
he was what it would cost him to
self-actualize but now that he has I'm
invested in him enough that I'm excited
for Avatar 3 because he did all the
things I knew he had to do I was like
okay now now he's a butterfly dope we
got out of the Cocoon I'm excited to see
my boy my butterfly it's fair in that
particular case I don't necessarily feel
it as though the brother was like used
as a narrative device though I still
think they earned it and they earned
that that spark of a transformation that
he gives lowak in terms of other
characters though that felt like they
were largely there in service of other
characters Journeys the one that I felt
it with most
I guess in a negative sense was Nate
Tyrion Jake a lot of the times it felt
like natiri was going along with Jake's
Journey we're not not necessarily going
along with but there are particular
moments where he's making big decisions
for the clan and then ultimately for his
family that I would have loved a private
moment with her to see and feel how she
processed something and it just so
happens that Zoe Saldana is an absolute
master of being able to give someone
maximum emotion in a scene at the drop
of a hat and make you believe it so I
still think natiri plays quite well in
this movie but there were certain points
along the way where I'm like can I just
get into her headspace a little more and
and I also know that
that's the point of their relationship
that they're at I mean it's not
necessarily a new thing they've had kids
and time has passed but this is a
totally new situation that they're in
and you know she
she needs to go along with him but I
guess that brings me back to my my main
point is that like even when he decides
that it's best for the Sully family to
leave the forest and leave the omadakaya
clan the place and the clan that she has
known all her life
I think they sell the moment well enough
but it also really would have meant a
lot if we had just a couple minutes with
natiri where she really expressed how
she felt about that and maybe some
apprehension and then maybe coming to
the conclusion that yes indeed Jake is
right and this is the best path I I
agree and I and that's kind of what I
was speaking to with like moments of
disrespect in the first film is it
definitely felt like they were able to
blend into this world immediately they
were definitely able to like sacrifice
the place that they fought for for the
entire first film in like five minutes
and I get you've got to move the story
along but it all felt like it was at her
cost like I definitely felt like Jake
has just been a problem for natiri like
the entire her entire existence is like
I'm gonna come in and mess your home up
and then I'm gonna make you leave we got
these kids One's Gonna Die like I just
feel bad for her that Jake and maybe
that's another thing I maybe I have some
like guilt about like I identify with
this character boy does he mess up
people's lives so like there's a there's
a disconnect there because you're
identifying with your lead from the
first film and he only messes up the
people's lives he cares about and I get
that that's that's life and I get that
being a parent is hard and I get that
yeah he was super cruel to his middle
child but he also was disrespectful to
his Queen like his woman the person that
like got him to understand the ways of
nature I didn't feel like he listened to
her and I and I didn't love that I
definitely struggled a bit with it is a
movie not part of a
TV series it's a franchise not a TV show
and I think that this very quickly fell
into the Marvel problem and I do
consider it a problem where it is okay
to have an unresolved story if you know
you're getting a third one like the
Matrix did or whatnot but have a dot dot
dot an ellipses is different than a dash
and I think a dash is okay because it
implies a conjunction this felt like an
ellipses where I was like oh I don't
really know where spider came from there
wasn't a baby in that first movie who
was that kid running around and then
we've got this Immaculate Conception
girl I'm like where are these children
coming from without real explanations
like spider didn't make sense his
storyline didn't work for me the entire
time they were like the whole time they
were with the enemies he was like let me
help you guys out I'm sure this will go
very well he has no reason to like or
trust these people and he's helping them
he has no reason to like or trust these
people but like let's not forget he's a
kid he's a kid that didn't grow up with
like traditional parental figures and
also Jake and nateiri Never Never Fully
accepted him as one of their own and
then all of a sudden he is presented
with a version of his father who is
essentially giving him the experience of
being taken under one's Wing even though
I think spider almost always sticks to
like core beliefs and he does put a stop
to certain things when he can like he's
in a stressful life or death situation
and he's also probably experiencing
these much wanted emotions that he's
never been exposed to before so I don't
know all that that confusion there re
that it really worked for me and I also
think I have to give a lot of credit to
Jack Champion that is not an easy role
to play my God I didn't by his disbelief
when they were hurting those Island folk
I didn't like I didn't want months ago
like yeah bro you knew this was coming
maybe you were strong armed into it
maybe you're emotionally manipulated but
obviously these giant military guys
trying to kill your family are going to
hurt other people like it was so like
well yeah maybe the guy with the gun
that's been punching things is bad
spoiler alert he's a bad guy like it
just felt like you know he's a bad guy
he's gonna do a bad guy he's a bad guy
he's a bad guy I walk that back he is a
bad guy here here's the big question
with kwarich so OG original quartz bad
bad guy did Terrible Things he's dead so
this doesn't matter but he is not
redeemable
what percentage of OG quarrette is
recomquarage and does recomquarage still
have
the ability and should we even be
open-minded to him being able to evolve
maybe via OG kwara's son I feel like
that's going to be an interesting
commentary on reform uh you know the
prison system if people can grow if
people can evolve if that's gonna be a
commentary on nature versus nurture I'm
excited for that story but I would have
rather had it in a way that didn't
sacrifice spiders saving him and thus
negating everything Jake did if they
regrew another courage and was just like
hey there's a guy and maybe there's a
commentary on Plato's the cave in that
every time you get further out of the
Cave the Shadows dwindle and the art
becomes less of a representation the
original Self maybe two the Clone
becomes less of an interpretation the
original Self much like the like again
Plato's The Cave can be told in a myriad
of ways and cloning would be a
fascinating way to do that but instead
they were like hey everything this movie
tried to do everything that Jake was
trying to protect this dude's gonna
negate it every time he can every time
that you should take a right spider the
left and I was like bruh I don't like
you anymore you're out I'm done like I
just he kept making every wrong decision
you can make a few you can write it off
as being a kid you can write it off as
being emotionally manipulated but he was
just a problem
he caused problems I can't deny that I
do think that ultimately the big
problematic decision towards the end is
gonna wind up feeding into the franchise
in a positive manner
than I was for two because of two like
this might be
um a reverse Empire Strikes Back like I
might be you know the third one might be
the best of them because it's able to
tell the story that's now they've earned
this original story from telling these
tropes they had to get through maybe I
think the fourth one might be the really
incredible one because James Cameron
told me he's it was something to the
effect of I think I have uh some of some
of the quote here he said that when he
turned in the script for Avatar 2 the
studio gave him three pages of notes
when he turned in the script for three
he got a page of notes so like things
were improving so to speak when he
turned in the script for Avatar 4 the
only thing that the creative executive
wrote back to him was holy f word
as in like as he explained it goes nuts
in a good way how did you feel about the
run time did this movie justify it and
do you think you'd be open-minded to
getting an avatar 3-4 Beyond with a
three hour plus running time now I think
that's the standard now I think it needs
to be three hours like well you're not
in the standard in the movie Sense in
the Pandora sense like I think now that
we you immerse yourself right this isn't
a movie this is a theme park ride it's
an exp that's a compliment this is an
experience you're going on a journey
you're having a time where you've got a
ton of characters come in but you also
need the time to lean back and
experience this isn't a movie that you
lean forward in through all three acts
it's a movie that you lean forward Lean
Back Lean Forward experience then you
stay in the third act grips and riveted
but you have that experience in the
chair I don't think two hours works for
that I think you need to have times
where you're in the atmosphere of
Pandora I imagine we're going to be
visiting more worlds in the next one I
also want that kind of like I want to
watch the world unfold while I'm in it
and if we rush it won't work and I also
feel like this movie had stuff that I
wanted more of for example natiri
feeling betrayed for example spider
being emotionally manipulated so I felt
like some of his decisions were
Justified for example Jake just not
being I understood where he was coming
from but it would have nice it would
have been nice to see a little bit more
of his bond with his sons before one
died like I I definitely felt the bond
but I didn't feel it enough that I I
could justify him being an
overprotective father I felt it when
natiri was saying they're not soldiers
they're your sons I then would have
liked to have seen a moment where he
felt that towards them and and so like
shortening it would only I think rob me
of emotional connection I do I I think
your point with uh Nate Tyrion Jake
right there is spot is spot on
one of the reasons why I appreciated the
three-hour running time the most is
because I thought it made me very well
immersed in their family Dynamic to
justify a lot of those decisions that
had the movie been any shorter I don't
think they would have gotten to certain
emotional payoffs or or even made me
willing to believe in some of those like
is that a good decision or is that a bad
decision type of thing I think that you
needed all that meat behind it and that
lived an experience behind it in order
to make some of those beats work just
like in general though like I'll fully
admit I'm a human being I was in a
little bit of a panic stepping into a
three-hour plus movie worrying about
like needing to get up and go to the I
didn't drink anything the first time
because I really didn't want to miss
anything
it feels like some sort of attack
when there was running water um when
they first got to Pandora and that was
when I first had to pee and I was like
okay this is probably an exploratory
steamer in their show like everything
but then it became one of my favorite
scenes because I loved the worlds and I
was just like the water is pouring but
I'm so enthroned it was torture I didn't
feel the running time once either time I
saw it
I felt it in the third act and I think
that was more akin to me being like Oh
now all the things I thought are
happening and it wasn't the run time as
much as me going like okay here we are
and I've been sitting and it was more of
a physical thing than a mental thing I I
had no point was like I'm bored I was
just aware that I was like and now the
colors are colored in and we're ready to
roll so like yes and no I definitely
like I I wouldn't want it any shorter
but I was also aware that it was three
hours but I was okay with that I like
being on Pandora like if you throw those
glasses on me I don't want to take them
off I want to be in
so the big question here now at this
point with future films on The Way Slash
being planned is it actually possible
for this movie to make two billion
dollars at the box office James Cameron
himself has actually said I believe this
came from a from a GQ piece that he
informed the studio that this film
represented the worst business case in
movie history and that ultimately in
order for it to be profitable you had to
be something like the third or fourth
highest grossing film in history that
that's the threshold like can we are
just set an impossible near impossible
bar for yourself I just I gotta give
credit to the man we've talked about him
a few times in this and I've praised him
but the balls on Jane now there's no
balls on the navi you can see their
little loin class floating around but
there's no seeming genitalia the balls
on James Cameron make up for it the
sheer volume of that man and Swinging
balls he's like I'm gonna make a movie
13 years later and it's gonna need to be
the number three movie of all time and
then it opened a half a billion dollars
worldwide he did it like it will be fine
this movie's gonna have legs this movie
is going to do great over Christmas this
movie is going to be re-released 87
times this movie is going to be
something that you want to watch the
first and second of this movie is not
something that's going to translate to
home video You're Gonna Wanna release
this on the five year anniversary of the
tenure it's gonna make money it's gonna
be fine it's it's gonna make money I
think doing great at the box office is a
different thing than doing what this
movie needs to do to turn a profit I
think 2 billion compared to 1.5 billion
two completely different things I do
think that this movie is going to be
quite successful it debuted at one uh
134 million dollars in North America and
435 million globally so it's already
made a lot but those numbers are
slightly below expectations I do think
that we're going to get a lot of repeat
viewings it is very clear that like the
road is clear for this movie to have
legs there are no big Blockbuster type
movies standing in its way and stopping
it from having to rely on a strong
opening weekend and not much more I do
think it's going to get repeat viewings
but again becoming one of the top five
grossing movies of all time
when the box office isn't fully back the
box office is is back a good percentage
a good deal we're still not at the
levels where it was and that's why I
think I think 1.5 billion is a very high
number a very impressive number that's
the more realistic number that we should
be talking about versus 2 billion I
think uh it's gonna also be a
conversation of looking at Avatar 4. uh
you know it's it's we've heard how much
of the next one is is built into this
one we've heard the budget of this one
involves the impact of the other ones I
think that yes that is a great sound
bite and I I just I hadn't heard it and
I just laughed at it but James Cameron's
like horrible decision at the same time
that's its own marketing if you say
something as bold as this needs to be
the number three thing of all time how
many other filmmakers can be like hey
the studio backed a movie that has to be
the number three film of all time and
really it has to be something that folds
into number three M4 to overall bring in
the 6 billion or whatever it needs but
as far as marketing goes genius and I do
think honestly I don't think it's going
to clear 2 billion I don't think it's
going to be the number three of all time
but I do think that's what everyone's
seeing for Christmas I do think that no
one's gonna be like hmm am I seeing
Babylon or Avatar you know what your
decision is you're not gonna you're not
gonna randomly but choose between the
two big Christmas movies if you're going
to the movies you're probably choosing
Avatar or one of the others but like as
a family you're going to Avatar so I do
think it's going to actually be a
smaller drop off than most people are
expecting as far as like week one to
week two bracket bracket two usually is
a staggering like you know 40 to 60
percent I think it's gonna be like 30.
uh I think it's going to do well and I
think the legs are going to get it
through February you know what's likely
going to give it even more legs even
longer legs not more legs it would be
longer legs otherwise it would have many
legs and that that might be weird
um but it's a movie Whatever Oscars
because I feel fairly certain about the
fact that this movie is gonna clean up
when it comes to Oscar nominations koi
where do you stand on that what is this
getting nominated for and will it go on
to win anything every special effect
Oscar is deserved uh the sound design is
deserved uh the score is reserved for a
nomination I don't know about win
because it was a great year in scores
um I don't necessarily seeing a getting
a best picture nomination because
because no because I respect your
opinion but no I respect your opinion
Amelia disagree with it I think we're
living in an age where the academy is
looking at what they're putting their
votes behind and know that their very
genre reluctant they don't put their
votes and I think this is going to be an
example of them putting their votes
behind other genre releases and not this
one because they don't do like all like
if they do 10 nominations two or genre
films I don't see this one being one of
the only two with this year's stacked I
think everything ever once is gonna take
over this I've been top gun Maverick is
going to take over this like like we've
got a blockbuster and a weird movie
those are the two that might eat away at
the Avatar chances I think that
everything everywhere all at once in Top
Gun Maverick are are basically
guaranteed best picture nominations I
think they have the better chances of
winning but I do think and and I think
there's really no doubt in my mind that
Avatar the way of water is going to get
a Best Picture nomination also because
think of what you just said it's gonna
get so many nominations and so much love
in all the crafts categories that all
feeds into best picture and also what do
they get like an a cinema score the
other good thing here is that it's a
crowd-pleasing movie that I'm not saying
everybody loves but the majority seem to
really enjoy it and I think that could
feed into the best picture conversation
when it comes to the Academy's
resistance to include many Blockbusters
in that particular conversation what I
sadly think happened not for Avatar but
for this other movie is I think with
Avatar's success I have bumped black
panther wakanda forever out of my best
picture conversations but I'm still
keeping it in other categories but I do
think that right now way of water is
very safe with the best picture
nomination I also think that James
Cameron has a real shot of getting a
Best Director nomination the visual
effects race
if not for top gun Maverick I think
because I think that still is a chance
of winning I do think it should be over
I think it should be handed to Avatar
the way of water there's just so many
revolutionary things look out for
cinematography I'm leaning against maybe
maybe score here I don't I think there's
too much I think there's competition
score and it was it was good but it
wasn't exceptional I love James Horner
and using some of his pieces were great
and I do think directing I don't
necessarily see cinematography because
of what a year it was I mean maybe a nom
but I don't see it at number one you had
you have to consider how it's like such
a completely different craft in
particular like the categories that come
to mind in that respecter cinematography
and something like production design
where their traditional craft needs to
be executed in such a unique way because
of the effects involved in this movie
and I I think those those corners of the
industry are going to respect that they
had to add like a whole new layer to
their craft in order to achieve what we
see in the finished product I think
there's also a reason Andy Circus has
want an Oscar though I I you know I mean
if they look at it though I could go
into the performance capture
conversation for a long long time but
you know what I mean if
there's cinematography then they'd also
have looked at Andy Circus and I hope
the academy has evolved in 10 years but
the fact that Andy Circus didn't get a
number of wins at this point always has
me going like okay let me look at the
when does this shift and maybe this is
when it shifts but I always have a
little asterisk when it comes to these
big Blockbusters in the academy other
Awards absolutely but the actual Academy
Awards always feels like they want
things that are tragically biopic and
they want things that are you know based
around Hollywood and they want things
that are it's it's a little it's a
little uh half for them two-thirds for
them and a third for us and I just don't
know where this is gonna land for that
third well we're breaking the molds I I
hope this is the thing that happened
Coda they're shaking things up with the
top gun Maverick and every everything
everywhere all at once in particular
being talked about in those in those
conversations to such an extent is very
exciting to me in my movie of the year
getting some love banshees of initial in
getting all that Irish flavor out there
my people getting respect people now
know like the love of donkeys and they
learn
what about when it comes to your
personal rankings about where does
Avatar the way of water fall for you uh
This is Gonna sound uh very very low but
it's been an for me an incredible year
um I've had an incredible time at the
movies this year I don't know if it's
because of lockdown and getting back in
the theater means so much to me I don't
know if it's because of like the shared
human connection of going to events
around people I don't know what it is
but to me 2022 has been a resounding
year in cinema uh this is like 18 17 18
in my top 20. that's fair I mean this
this really has been a very special I'm
currently in the very stressful process
of paring down my top ten I think I've
hit 13 and like it's it's breaking my
heart into a million pieces
so the fact that I'm saying Avatar the
way of water is in my top 20 is is very
high praise because I very I very easily
could also produce a top 20 of 2022 and
feel like that strongly about all of
those movies so it is quite the
accomplishment it's very high up in my
rankings let's take a moment to look
ahead a little bit koi so I believe
where they stand with Avatar three and
four John Landau the producer of course
has said
Avatar 3 principal photography on that
movie is 90 95 finished when it comes to
Avatar 4 they've filmed the First Act of
the movie so so that's that's where we
stand right now what are you hoping is
in those movies based on what you see
and want more of in way of water I
assume we're gonna visit more places I I
know that they landed in the Water World
at the end and they accepted them as one
of their own and and you know they had
that moment of like I'm I'm part of the
tribe now and I love that but I I don't
think they stay there uh I think James
Cameron loves elements I think we're
gonna get uh you know what's the band
Earth Wind and Fire I think we've had
Earth I think we've had water I think
we're gonna get like some sort of fire
Nabi and then some sort of like windy
Navi uh I think we're gonna go through
the elements of the world of Pandora I
don't know how to win Navi looks like
Wendy Navi yeah I don't know do they
live like in the sky maybe there's maybe
the people that stay Ariel like we saw
underground Navi too yeah we could see
an earth Navi that's different I I see
us going Elemental I'm literally trying
to figure out the most like unusual
place a navi could exist now and
determine that I want that plasma Navi I
think they they have talked a little bit
about the idea of exploring additional
Clans in the future films and I think in
one interview out there I'm pretty sure
it came up that there might be material
that takes place on Earth in the future
which is uh very interesting to me and I
think brings up a whole lot of a lot of
possibility interesting possibilities
there when it comes to the specific
characters I'll go back to what I said
before
I want more natieri I want a a deeper
look at like her headspace and how she's
feeling about like the time has passed
to do that with the events of Avatar the
way of water as they unfold but I want
Avatar 3 to let me sit with her while
she processes what she just went through
I feel like that scene with spider
afraid of her is an indicator of what I
love that incredible moment that is one
of my favorite moments of the entire
movie thing and that's that's the moment
I liked both natiri and spider's
representation of the end of their arcs
and that took some of the rockier
moments for me so it absolutely had a
payoff and again I'm more excited for
three because of those moments but I do
think that was an indicator of where
we're going with her I she didn't say
like my Jake until after that I think
she was going through trauma of like
feeling for him again and like coming I
feel like he's her anchor of like I lost
myself and you're my you're my rock
you're my anchor you're my Jake and I
want to see that from him again I felt
like he was disrespectful to the queen
and that bothered me throughout so I
want to see their bond get stronger
again I want to see them maybe Bond over
the loss of a child I want to see I
think Jake was and and for the acting
standpoint I was never bothered by Sam
Worthington I just didn't have a lot of
like I was neutral I was like that guy
did what he needed to do I was so
impressed with Sam we're in the same way
of water I think he gave an incredible
performance and I always think Zoe
Saldana is one of the most talented
powerful energetic people on the planet
it goes back to the level of Technology
you get so much more access to their
performance this time I'm sure their
performances were just as good in the
flesh the last time but with this
technology you see like the tiniest
detail in their facial expressions and
every ounce of emotion that they're
exhibiting it's something else going
back to seeing the the evolution of
their relationship though we had about
this many Bros and this many my Jakes so
the amount of bros there were more
cousins six that was it was my Jake's
cousins Bros if you watch this three
hour Journey with like a Four Loco and
just drink it it has to be like a
Guinness World Record the amount of time
bro is uttered in this movie without
Paul Walker yes I think that the the
Jake was summoning his Paul Walker and I
love and respect and miss the great Paul
Walker but the Bros and cuz quotient was
damn near Orange County here's another
thing that I really want in the next
movie I want more time with recumbitch
understanding what it means to be a
Recon like one of the things that
fascinates me most about that character
and I guess the previous version of him
as well is like Juarez essentially
agreed to become the thing he hated most
and as Stephen Lang explained it to me
he was basically like following
corporate orders you know he didn't
think he was gonna die he was just doing
the thing he was told because it wasn't
going to happen anyway but now that it's
happened and recomquarage still has the
understanding of the navi that original
quarrych had in the the first film
that's gotta be like a mind like you
know what type of situation of coming to
terms with like who he has become
compared to who he was before and where
he'll need to go in the future so I'm
I'm very eager to I guess explore more
of that particular technology and what
percent of OG and recomquarage
ultimately is in this next movie yeah
and I think Stephen Lang like you don't
cast that man he's not one note there's
a lot more to say and I think his
villain in the first one was incredible
now we're seeing a little bit more
Nuance in this one not that the villain
was a Nuance but like he was a bad guy
and I kind of liked that it was good to
have a bad guy on screen that was a bad
guy like the T-1000 is a bad guy like
you there is a difference between
nuanced villain and mustache twirling
there's there's a there's a middle
ground of just villainy and I think that
slang did that well in the first one I
now want to see it go a little bit of
the other way in the third one I want to
see a little bit more of like what his
thought process is why he he feels so
connected to this this mission that
isn't test technically his and and
whether he fights against you know the
the corporation like the the yes and
Soldier mentality I feel like we could
talk for for maybe 13 years about Avatar
the way of water but we're not allowed
to have that kind of time so we have to
wrap this up koi as always it is a
pleasure talking movies with you you
have made my brain spin in new ways yet
again and I appreciate it before we let
you go can you tell everybody out there
where they could find your wonderful
work on the internet you can find me at
koijandro
c-o-y-j-a-n-d-r-e-a-u on Twitter on tick
tock on Instagram
um over at the real rejects I'm over at
New rockstars a lot I'm starting some
new stuff in the New Year I've got a
podcast called koi cast I don't like
sleep I don't like rest but I do love
art so I like sharing it with y'all
rest up and celebrate all of your hard
work of 2022 in this this last little
bit of time here please my friend
you've earned it all right that is it
I'm gonna say a big thanks to everybody
out there watching this we will see you
next time with a brand new after show
[Music]